does pineapple belong on pizza okay stop
Sweden cease your pineapple and raises
you an honour on pizza
curry on pizza and kebab on pizza
seriously Sweden so let's forget about
pineapple because here in Sweden they
have a completely different take on
pizza here it's a pizza topping
free-for-all my med has been cooking
pizzas for 25 years and he will tell you
anything goes
things like banana banana it'sa the yet
devotee a shaker he'll walk so net this
special for vintage moon deity Burnham
and Anna's curry so what do the Swedes
eat in the summer the huorchi bar
patrons from heaven Mamma Mia after
Malaika fash give up food and oven
Malaga row especially
brolic rotten water Oh pepperoni two
witnesses were so sleepy a staff can sit
there on I mean who doesn't love a kebab
so ocean of la pasta pizzeria what's on
your menu vehicle Brad Corbin on video
company owner shrimp
Oh st. so Sweden oh there's more there's
curry pizza which is chicken banana
curry and pineapple or my favorite
Tropicana
ham banana and or Pyrenees mm-hmm why
this isn't just a late-night snack is it
Nirvana tosses ganache apep its Italian
the gamma ray with the festival OPC and
so on partner orchid redondela long term
pizza at the Empress Amira
now for the real question why did Sweden
reinvent an already perfect food diet
mojado
x-parameter otoscope agravada blonde
dinner so they made a small clay he says
kebab pizza and Rafi Boniface I think
you can delay gabbana pockets are some
anonymous so what the end only smoke day
and now the most important part that
tastes really good
[Music]
now first I was like Sweden banana
doesn't go on a pizza but you know what
it's actually quite tasty surprised me
click the link below for more episodes
from the try it like it season